of all the iconic stories to emerge from
the League of Legends World
Championships a few are as memorable as
the Taipei assassins run in 2012 the
Taiwanese outfit became overnight
sensations not only for their incredible
play but for decisively overcoming
arguably the three strongest teams at
the tournament in a series of
history-making upsets this is when
assassins ruled the world heading into
the 2012 World Championship everyone's
eyes were fixed on a pair of teams to
win it all there was Moscow 5 the CIS
juggernaut who had dominated the scene
thanks to their innovation and
aggression and Korea's azubu frost a
team whose fearsome reputation caused
opposing teams and their fans across the
world to quake in their boots this
fanfare was not the case for the Taipei
assassins in fact they were a massive
question mark heading into the
tournament a total Dark Horse they're
all but non-existent experienced against
international competition caused many to
view them with uncertainty and although
they had utterly dominated their home
region thanks to strong team
coordination and creative play it was
unknown how that would translate against
the world's best on league's biggest
stage but as we all know assassins work
best with the element of surprise as
champions of their region the Taipei
assassins were seated directly into the
playoff bracket and their first opponent
wasn't going to be an easy one
they were slated to face Korea's second
representative the intimidating nation
sort who had steamrolled their group
while TPA were coming in cold led by Lau
toys why Ken and his now legendary
Orianna
game 1 was a statement of intent proving
that the Taipei assassins weren't going
to back down again
anybody before you has chance to react
so that was he gets a second song he'll
get drops as well that's gonna be Coco
freaking out but what you still get
straight down don't go for the triple
kill for the baby and offer leave a
little place they just wanted to catch
the ariana hopes but again in a game
toys it's just reading in my mark that's
gonna be a deterrent that could easily
take it even off the back of this one
honestly Gigi's given surrounded by
sausage thank you can't one against that
team to started out with nausea to jump
in the counter strikes up lunges gonna
pick up on him should be out of
finishing well fact he's gonna tank this
one up and it's gonna be prey their
picks up there Gail but the assassins
clawed their way back into it with some
ferocious team fighting no balls show me
very like that watch he's gonna get
dropped us an Oracle down Bilbo
meanwhile they capture us what song song
gets dropped as well this is a great
turnaround by diverse assets a guy it's
and the taipei assassins superior map
control team fight execution and
coordination overwhelmed of their korean
add mercer e courage assault police
fight back they need to keep this fight
up they need to or they will be out the
disarmament charlie no consignment
doesn't get the whole eggs off the back
of that one and nothing solid vitiating
could that be side by assassins going
through that grossing for the nexus 5 GG
assassins surprising everyone but that's
out in the sweep over najin caught the
world's attention the Taipei assassins
passionate celebrations and infectious
energy captivated viewers just as much
as their unexpectedly high level of play
said earlier you can only be as good as
the competition you're playing against
what GPS kind of proof is wrong there TV
a song true importance I mean what's
this it don't know how about waiting the
gun power down yeah wow the wind brought
cautious optimism to their new fans
there was still much work to be done why
because Taipei assassins next opponent
was going to be an even bigger test the
love Omer Hayden moscowfive
taking down a tournament favorite like
Moscow five would be no easy task and
after getting torn apart in the first
game of the series
the obvious question was whether or not
TPA were up to the challenge
but that question was answered
definitively in Game two on ghost you
can lock them down with the turret
Stanley gets out of that and it's just
huge pressure from Taipei assassins
right now Darien is however able to
clean up a few kills for his team it's
now three two three a four to three now
finally the last Auto Attack and double
kill for toys the ace on the moscowfive
they're gonna gain some huge ground here
as they turn moscowfive face in to
shambles moscowfive not exactly
flustered but I think this is the first
time we have seen them not be able to
answer a strategy toys just back down to
his team and it's gonna be that second
at first Nexus toriel
the second Nexus turret then Nexus now a
game three moscowfive forced to defend
on the fountain and it's going to be a
huge matchup your first semifinal match
going into a best of three between
Taipei and Moscow five in a deciding
third game the Taipei assassins
continued their onslaught by mixing up
their strategy focusing on objective
control instead of teamfights and by the
20-minute mark they had a 5 to 0 tower
lead over Moscow 5 and I'm surprised
actually played it as a split push but
it's actually working out and pulled in
by their sizable gold lead the assassins
went for Moscow fives jugular goes down
Terry gets caught out he can't even off
with a crescendo stopping them from
using the abilities diamond price goes
down the inhibitor is open the double
kill comes out fast on five looking very
grim right now taipei assassins look to
take down the last Nexus 10 and they
will trap Moscow 5 from the League of
Legends championship playoffs and would
you look at that the Sears the yells at
the look at relief of all mixed in the
same time on their faces taipei assassin
- the first team to make it to the World
Finals after two dramatic upsets the
Taipei assassins had made it to the
finals only to have to face the final
boss azubu frost who had been living up
to their terrifying reputation
to a push lane instead of a stone comes
illusion from behind the dust bringers
out so he has the speed Tyrande side
here's the 3d one but the congregates
want the end the turn is right left
he could turn this around shine comes
out with a kill in a 3d one situation to
run out like finally goes out rugged
ultimate it's conventions on these out
left but rapid flowers in that wood is
either destroy the opposition grandpa's
going to down south they have super
minions coming up the midline this could
well be the end today's typical at the
ace that is the game azubu frost there
in the final it was going to be a
slugfest the dark horse that had toppled
two Titans on route to the finals
against the expected champions but the
Taipei assassins did not care for
expectations
armed with steadfast self belief and
backed by a legion of ravenous
supporters they charged into the game
coming around the side that guy - here
comes amumu coming around the side she's
heading towards it nothing going up
though I think she might go down before
they get a chance to finish it up
[Applause]
say please Oh enough Stanley coming down
the side that bag the act is gonna go
about that way you've done
he takes both articles out man can they
turn it off the wound just more borax
will you get this load out Scotty appear
to be other tank 2 turns up they are
going to go this one thank you now how
they goes up to take my life
[Applause]
however azubu frost would begin to turn
things around off the back of a
now-famous Quadra kill by rapid star on
Karthus co flick of an apple bourbon
isn't enough toys and surely you get
both these down to an egg right now
about ten flowers inside but the damage
really coming from his room at the back
eventually the Koreans would seal game
one ball shy girl 54 killed 42-minute
victory despite giving up the lead in
the series the Taipei assassins would
bounce back in game 2 thanks to Sun lil
balls Quan posed jungle dr. mundo which
caught as Ubu frost completely off-guard
madlife warty candy coated with a
cleaver he's got a cleaver on he's fast
in he gets exhausted it's the Levi's bad
luck but they're gonna turn it down
that's gonna be first but it is BBA
picks it up once a game here we see toys
potentials and there's a teleport from
toys auto-paint not quite light never
rappers birth to me yet I'll shed new
the reverb this goes in that us can be
shed to the cross they can try and get
up toward site rapid stars gonna get
drunk and they take shine as well I do
whoops as he can lubos getting involved
hasten to home he walked up one roof go
join your baggage
fifteen against the fella from which
Bobby's ex no one's gonna cobble that
type a something well take game 2 in
game 3 - I saw Rihanna would make a
triumphant return away shockwaves like
that boom
that's gonna be an hour go bad for toys
we're trying to pull turning out in
Stanley with the ball on him he's gonna
jump back off we're gonna get this right
what might say assassinating azubu frost
in a surrender they knew the game was
over azubu frost they just wanted to get
on to the next game that could be a
smart call they knew that lingering in
that game was only going to demoralize
them so they decided to end it early the
Taipei assassins were one win away from
the unlikeliest of world titles and in
Game four they showed azubu frost and no
mercy forced away in it I tell you what
my life is completely out of position
he's gonna try and back off from here
and he's trying to teleport him who is
not getting a child trapped he is
trapped has he managed to escape me
though with that will that little pixie
get spotty he has my eyes gonna go let's
go away
never going to escape this one that
kills me give us a choice
dog is full combo GP is feeling very
confident now because Oh big fight up
top that pressure goes towards my life
that might be true shobhraj just my
mistakes
Wow cloudtemplar going straight in there
the Luna thought possible absolute zero
go stop Stanley taking those nut house
the back way now don't forget drop by
mistake can they do the aggression oh
really go twice oh here comes a time
there comes is the short wave gonna come
out those instantly pulls the ball and
slam these Manny's gonna find come
across bad tempers gonna get go Italian
you will go down eventually his toys
that picks up the kill okay
the group was exhausted taipei assassins
I better continue diving on this one we
with a lunar ultra is gonna walk away
from that and again the hello baby
trueshot barrage makes that work with
total map control and a 17 K gold lead
the Taipei assassins went for the
killing blow
Oh
[Applause]
they had done it the Taipei assassins
had an fatica Li taken down three of the
world's best teams to become world
champions they took down the cream of
the crop nation sword looked on stop
blood of group stage Moscow flat was the
favorites coming into the tournament
who's the first one against the
champions of Korea and then take three
games in a row the Taipei assassins run
has become something of a legend it
comes from a time when league of legends
was still growing and theirs was easily
one of the most exciting storylines to
grace the game up to that point sure
looking back on the games now we can see
how far the competitive scene has come
the macro decisions team fighting and
execution are far more developed today
but the Taipei assassins story at Worlds
2012 still embodies the amazing spirit
of league's early days the passion the
fun the triumphant underdog how can you
not love that
[Applause]
[Music]
that is just awesome thanks for watching
if you want more great content be sure
to hit that subscribe button
[Music]